how's it going guys welcome to the
broken podcast my name is Pierre to
crack way to me
it's the toast years of toast cinnamon
toast can I bet you didn't expect to see
me here this time last week we had
rubrics or Nova's against yeah good
times I think we talk more in depth than
we've done in a long time and I feel
like I really know a soul mate for those
who don't know last week we set up our
OkCupid which is a dating website along
with Nova and we we Photoshop ourselves
into girls and see how many dick pics
each one of us get so tell me Kenneth
how many dick pics did you get I didn't
get any because that's my profile got
shut down that day oh that excuse I got
oh my god Jane you diggin anything no
one even get favourites I got so many
favorites but then I I mean it's it's
really weird I don't know how it
happened but I mind mine got shut down
too I thought I mean I thought I had a
pretty convincing description of like a
real person you know I was getting
really into it no I was getting a lot of
girls um boys I mean whatever he was
getting so instead of going through our
own profiles which we were gonna do
today we'll review our profiles
since they got shut down we decided to
look up we looked up not OkCupid posts
things like other day web sites where
people are creepy and leaving weird
messages we just picked out the best
ones that we liked stuff that I'd
probably posed if um uh de youtube if
what if I didn't youtube i I'd just be
doing this [ __ ] and YouTube you just put
you just go and be creepy on yeah no I'm
super creepy I have no idea yeah yeah
yeah so like an example here our first
one here it's just it's just a message
and it's pretty simple it just says our
matches 69% I think that's a sign and
the replies I think not no okay maybe
not had to try that's pretty basic I
don't really know that one's done
there's just like hey yeah we had a 69%
maybe it's a 69 his why I said that yeah
that's it that's it now we put two and
two together
ah well you didn't get that I didn't at
first ah I have one which is from Dave
he's from Philly and telephone he's 35
years old he looks like he is a
librarian who likes to read fantasy
novels
he's got that business suit in this way
pilot he does Hannity kind of [ __ ]
looks like you had to be honest me he
found someone with an 82% match and he
said have my baby what the [ __ ] are you
doing
well let's just tell people to have
their babies I like I like that look he
has he's just like such a smug smile and
he's like staring deep and he's got like
this old man he's shadowing you verb
right next to him he's like at my baby
at Bobby anger at my baby it's probably
the old man back there is it's not
actually 35 is like before my baby okay
anyway we have a whole story here of a
guy trying to get hooked up at a hotel
so I'll be I'll be the oh maybe I maybe
I don't know maybe some girl who knows
this uh so do I get to be you get to be
the darker gray ones okay I'm well
excited would you like to have fun
together I'm allowed to invite you to
the best place for a fabulous night
question mark what please no question
mark
hey look so tell I look sad I'm okay I'm
going up scared I'm not into hotels why
it's a spectacular place like VIP room
well I better [ __ ] get over there
then I can't help myself
ass guys do convincing they make me feel
uneasy I don't like highest class [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] kind of skanky my high
class [ __ ] is not hot class stuff is
enjoyable night okay anyway you don't
have to you huh I just don't like it
Hotels an expensive stuff
okay let's go not expensive one where
are you comfortable with and why can't
stay for a night the [ __ ] are these like
twelve year olds who hacked you like
went into the website yeah a little
better than this my readings terrible
not like haha no I'm not going to a
hotel with a random person it's not a
random person wait it's not a random
take it easy a person invites you nicely
to a good place for a night to have fun
and enjoyable your night enjoy your
night yeah all right just take it easy
you [ __ ] this guy up so where's so
sweet I carried it a night draft five
but you will know me I don't want to
hurt you
yet the [ __ ] that's good red flag right
there I'm out yeah I don't want to hurt
you that means you're gonna [ __ ] kill
me